I think that Obama's term is really
george w bush's third term in office
he's been a disappointment for everybody
hi Matt Welch for recent TV here we're
at Freedom Fest in Las Vegas then with
Jacob for burger thank you for joining
us founder of the future of freedom
foundation it's a lot of alliteration
and a critic I would posit of American
foreign policy specifically
interventionist foreign policy like to
talk a little bit about that looking at
the current administration and the
president in particular can you assess
sort of what is the level of continuity
with the two previous presidents and
foreign policy are there gradations of
differences when it comes to things like
American military intervention is
important policy I think that Obama's
term is really george w bush's third
term in office he's been a
disappointment for everybody he is
continuing the whole paradigm of
intervention ISM wars of aggression
occupations torture assassinations I
mean nothing's really changed so
hopefully something will change with the
next administration what what happened
to the anti-war left in the end the pro
civil liberties Pro closing down
Guantanamo left what's your kind of
assessments of where that movement went
to their man got into office and they're
like the Conservatives when george w
bush gunned office when their man got
into office their lips were sealed they
became silent they felt that it was a an
act of treason to go against their own
party man and so it's not doesn't apply
to all liberals i mean some of them have
been very very stout and defending civil
liberties through the obama
administration but by and large they've
proven to be as much a disaster as when
conservatives get there man and office
is it inevitable i mean not to be a
total pessimist or determinist on this
stuff but is it just inevitable that
once you hold the reins of this
particular power you have no real
incentive to dismantle it I think
amongst those people that look at
statism is their model is their home
because their dream look at the
political process in terms of if I can
just get my people in public office
that's all that matters yeah it's
hopeless but I mean that's where we
libertarians come in we provide the real
hope because we're not talking about how
to reform the state ism we're talking
about how do we get a paradigm change
where we we get a free society instead
of reformed warmed-over state of society
what do you see like on a kind of
populist or political undercurrents
possibilities or agitation for a more
libertarian or more or less
interventionist foreign policy is that a
more popular idea are there green shoots
coming up in that particular market now
I have never been more excited about
being in this movement than now I mean
I've never seen so much excitement about
libertarianism especially among young
people and here you have to libertarians
running for president you know Gary
Johnson and Ron all you've got Michele
Bachmann talking about Ludwig von Mises
and Hayek this is incredible then you
have all these young people that are
excited about this philosophy so for
those of us that have been working this
vineyard for decades these are exciting
times what do we have to look what's the
next signpost what's going to tell us
that that movement is growing and maybe
even has a snowball's chance in hell in
Washington of actually changing policies
or some of the ideas that we see a
capital that's a fascinating question I
think that's impossible to predict I
think it's going to be the results of
human action not of human design as pie
except pointed out that we all keep
working at what we're doing and then
somehow or another these ideas percolate
to the to the surface and they manifest
themselves in ways that none of us can
predict I think that's what's going to
happen that's great thank you very much
Jake important burger for recent TV I'm
Matt Welch